[Music]
you made dinner
wait what is that hot dogs and macaroni
perfect no notes we'll need new music
and choreography
shake it helen yep it's really great oh
we'll see about that
when they find out what i've got cooking
they're gonna
line up at bitsy soup kitchen for a
handout and i'll say get away from my
soup it's made for me
now i want soup
[Music]
with these plans i'll be able to buy
central park you want to see
there you go too fast here take another
look oh too quick didn't see it so sad
[Music]
is this a judged competition with points
for style points for required movements
and points for that extra undefinable
something time to let my hair down
guess this is just the shape my hair is
now squirrel just nibbled my toe um
advice what's mom advice really good
advice given for free
we hit the mother lode scooch over i'm
getting in please don't be naked
put drinky in mouthy
[Music]
i'm freaking out the lies will drown
this family we're the best family ever
remember and we're having fun
say it we're having fun
[Music]
you